wish i played in his generation yeah you  wish you would have played in his  generation yeah why i heard he was like  like just how he you know go about the  game you know just that mindset he had  i would like to know play against him so  yeah  you know yeah this time you're not  saying i would have cooked uh i would  have cooked them too  you would have cooked michael jordan  nobody got more confidence than 12.  now that's what you're supposed to say  and say nobody gonna beat me in  one-on-one or anything yeah i don't care  what it is what sport it is soccer who  the best player in soccer  someone we can play  who would you say best  matter of fact somebody set it up set up  you and messi  for sure you know how hard that is  though right  for sure okay but you still want to try  i'm confident